[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends want to hear an amazing
fact on a clear afternoon in styler
Kouga alabama in 1954 and hodges a
homemaker was hit by a meteorite she was
napping on a couch when a softball sized
fragment crashed through the roof of
their farmhouse ricocheted off the radio
and hit her on the hip to this day she's
the only American that's known to have
ever been hit by a meteorite very few
people in the world that we know of
actually gets struck and fewer still
lived to talk about it but she will go
down in history for receiving an
out-of-this-world bruise in story is
particularly rare because only about
5,000 meteorites the size of a baseball
or bigger hit the earth each year and of
course most of them land in the sea or
land and no one ever sees it one
astronomer said you have a better chance
of getting hit by a tornado and a bolt
of lightning and a hurricane all at the
same time as opposed to being hit by a
meteorite do you know the Bible talks
about a large stone that will strike the
world near the end of time stay with his
friends we're gonna learn more on this
edition a Bible answers lie
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 seven two nine
seven and we're also streaming on
facebook if you want to watch and that's
at the Doug Batchelor Facebook page or
you can go to the amazing facts Facebook
page and we'll be streaming Bible
answers live and I am Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
listening friends and pastor Doug as we
always do let's start the program with
prayer dear father we thank you that we
can take this time to open up your word
and study together and we ask for the
Holy Spirit to be with us here in the
studio and those who are listening
wherever they might be father lead us
into clearer understanding what the
Bible says for we asses in Jesus name
Amen amen
pastor you open the program by talking
about well a very rare occurrence first
of all a meteor striking the earth is
not something that happens too often
that people know about it and then a
media striking a person is even more
rare but then a media striking a person
and the person survives is very rare and
very rare indeed you can actually see a
picture in and her large bruise
online and they substantiated afterward
they brought on some geologists they
looked at the rock and poor thing they
took the rock for me she said it's my
rock it hit me and they didn't give it
to her you know that was back during the
Cold War and they thought maybe maybe
it's
you know a Russian plot or something and
they confirm yet wasn't meteorite and
then I let up with a statement that said
you know the end of the world is
connected with a stone falling from the
heavens now it's not that the Bible
foretells the world is going to be
struck by an asteroid or a meteorite but
there is a prophecy in Daniel 2 that
connects the end of the world with this
large stone that strikes an image on the
earth and then that stone grows into a
great mountain and that vision can be
found in Daniel chapter 2 and it's a vim
it's a vision a dream given to King
Nebuchadnezzar Daniel who's living in
Babel and then comes to interpret the
dream for the king and that great image
that Idol represents all the false
religions of the world and these
kingdoms that would rule from the time
of Nebuchadnezzar these great empires
through Persia in Greece and Rome and
the divisions of the Roman Empire and
then it portrays a stone Daniel says he
sees a stone cut out of a mountain
without hands and it comes down and it
strikes the image on the feet and
pulverizes this great Idol and it grows
into a great mountain meaning the
kingdom of God fills the earth and this
is this is a symbol of Christ's coming
and wiping out every other earthly
Kingdom and filling the world with his
kingdom now we have an offer if you've
never studied that vision it's one of
the most phenomenal prophecies in the
Bible a matter of fact I know a lot of
evangelists that it's the first
presentation they make if they're
inviting people to an evangelistic
prophecy series because it's so
compelling how accurately this vision
outlines the history of the world from
the days of Daniel down to our day and
ultimately a Christ coming and so we got
a free offer that talks about this it's
a lesson that deals with the subject and
pastor Russ tell us about it it's a part
of our series of lessons we don't offer
this too much so it's not a one that we
do often but it's a great study and it
deals with the subject of Daniel chapter
2 it's called millennial man the
Millennial man and it's our first in a
series of studies called the story
coalescence
so if you'd call and ask for that we'll
be happy to send you this lesson it's
again called millennial man and the
number to call is 808 three four eight
three five six seven four seven
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone line
and you can ask for the study guide
called or the lesson called millennial
man that's lesson number one in
historical set we're gonna go to our
first caller today we've got an applet
listening in Charlotte North Carolina
Matt welcome to the program
hey guys love your ministry well thank
you is Christianity a religion or
relationship all the above none of the
above
I'll hold the studio audience well I
would say that Christianity is a
religion based upon a relationship you
can't deny that Christianity is a
religion and there's nothing wrong with
religion if it's true and talking about
having a you know regimented spiritual
system of beliefs that's good you know
Jesus taught doctrine with authority and
the people were amazed at his teaching
so there's nothing wrong with that but
all of the Christian religion is
ultimately based upon a love
relationship first of all between God
and us you know God finds us and He
loves us and that changes our heart and
we learn to love our fellow man and
those are the two great Commandments are
all about a relationship love for God
and love for your fellow man absolutely
it's about a love relationship but you
know teaching that love relationship you
could call the religion so I guess it's
kind of a semantic puzzle does that make
sense net well I guess you know
sometimes people say if you do
sacraments the right way or you know you
wear the right clothes to church or you
say the right words the prayer book or
whatever then blessings be upon you and
I you know sometimes I regard that as
religion maybe I'm mistaken that
thinking I think I know what you're
saying there is a legalism whenever a
person thinks that by going through a
set of actions they're going to be saved
by this regiment the Bible is really
clear that
no man is justified by works we are
justified by faith and ultimately their
works we do the good works we might do
must be based on love not on trying to
save ourselves so jesus said if you love
me keep my Commandments even in the Ten
Commandments I think it's the second
commandment where God says showing mercy
unto thousands of them that love me and
keep my Commandments it's all about a
love relationship and then you you know
you if you're doing the prayers and if
you're doing any good deeds for your
fellow man that should be based on love
relationship with God and with your
fellow man that's a good question I
think a lot of people wonder what comes
first and now if you say well I don't
love the Lord enough don't stop doing
the good things the praying and the
attending church and you know giving
food to the poor all those things are
good they should continue but you always
want to be doing them for the right
reason which would be love for your
neighbor and love for God by the way how
do you get more love for God how do you
love anyone you get to know them we know
God through his speaking to us through
his word and we know him as we speak to
him through prayer and so it's through
communication reading his word and
prayer our love grows thank you
appreciate your question next hole of it
be happy sadly listening in Utah sunny
welcome to the program hey pastor Doug
yes thanks for calling I just wanted to
know what it means in the Bible it says
the kingdom of God is within you
like it's not going to be like a place
well and that's a good question but
please don't misunderstand there's two
aspects to the kingdom
you've got the kingdom of God that
happens when a person first accepts
Christ and Jesus reigns in our hearts he
has first place we're seeking first his
kingdom and righteousness when God you
know when Jesus began preaching he said
the kingdom of God is at hand meaning as
soon as you accept Christ Paul says do
not let sin reign your kings usually
reign on a throne we're saying don't let
sin reign in your heart the Lord reigns
in our hearts Paul says sin shall not
have dominion over you again
using Kingdom language Christ reigns he
has dominion over our hearts our minds
our lives he is our king we obey his
commands but then there is a literal
Kingdom a physical Kingdom because even
in the Lord's Prayer when we say thy
kingdom come
while his kingdoms already comes to the
inside but ultimately Christ is going to
come and destroy all the kingdoms of the
world as we said in our opening
illustration tonight and we do have that
lesson that talks about that God's
physical kingdom that will come with the
stone so does that make sense Sally yeah
thank you all right thank you very much
and do ask for that lesson on the
Millennium man or millennial man I think
you're gonna find encouragement in that
study again the number to call is 808
three five six seven four seven that is
the resource phone line and ask the free
offer it's called millennial man and
that's our first lesson in historical
set up lessons a next caller that we
have is Jason listening in Toronto Jason
welcome to the program thank you for
having me thanks yes sir
my question is when Christ comes again
for the second time I understand that a
lot of people believe there will be
going to heaven but I'm not sure if I
have this correct but what he does come
again I've been told that he will turn
the earth into a set into a paradise and
we shall dwell in the earth forever so
my question is are we going to have it
or we meant to be bound to stay on the
earth forever and dwell there I'm glad
you asked that question because both
answers are somewhat correct first when
Christ comes we go up now let me give
you a scripture jesus said in John 14
you know let not your heart be troubled
neither let it be afraid in my father's
house are many mansions I go to prepare
a place for you so he went up says and
when I come again I will receive you
unto myself that where I go you might be
and you can read in 1st Thessalonians
when the Lord comes we are caught up to
meet him in the air so there's no
question we go up when Jesus comes then
you read in Revelation 20 we live and
reign with him for a thousand years
during what they call the Millennium and
at the end of the millennium you're
reading revelation 21 I believe the New
Jerusalem comes down
from God out of heaven on the earth so
the City of God where we're living with
Christ will ultimately be moved down to
this planet then it says he creates a
new heaven and a new earth wherein
dwells righteousness we ultimately live
on the earth you know Jesus said blessed
are the meek they will inherit the earth
it's an earth made new though you know
we have a study guide that deals with
this and I think you'll enjoy reading
adjacent it's called a thousand years of
peace and it's about that 1000 year
period that you read about in Revelation
chapter 20 and it talks about events at
the beginning at the end of that time
period what happens during the thousand
years just give us a call on our
resource phone line it's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and asked for the amazing fact study
guide called a thousand years of peace
did you know amazing facts has a free
Bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 for 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand my next call of the behalf is
listening in Clearwater Florida we have
Angelita on the phone
hi Angelita you on Bible answers life hi
good evening thank you for taking my
call my question deals with first Kings
chapter 863 and it was when Solomon was
dedicating the temple and it says that
he sacrificed twenty-two thousand cattle
and one hundred and twenty thousand
sheep and I'm wondering how this was
done in a period of seven days you know
well for one thing this is the zenith of
Israel's Kingdom I've been to the
mountain where the the temple is and up
at the Dome of the rock and you look
inside you can see they had a tunnel to
carry the blood so it was a big
operation they had a tunnel to carry the
blood from the temple site down to the
Kidron Valley you read in chronicles
David numbers the priests and there were
thousands of priests and Levites that
were assigned to deal with the
sacrifices sacrifice
so I've thought the same thing I read
the phenomenal number now they didn't do
that every year
I think Josephus says that during the
Passover that the Jews sacrificed two
hundred and fifty thousand lambs of
course that's over the course of a whole
week I there was a lot of blood coming
from the temple and yet for all of that
Josephus says there was no smell or any
insects they were so sanitary in the way
they dealt with it all but he just had
an incredible system yeah it was a big
operation no I wasn't all year long but
when Solomon dedicated the temple he
wanted to make a sacrifice to pass all
sacrifices and I'm not sure they even
did them all in the temple you know
sometimes they would they would do
sacrifices I guess they probably did
them all in the temple then for that
time I know one time it says that
Solomon made a big sacrifice to the Lord
in Gibeah but this is the one where he
dedicates the temple so it was probably
in the temple so you're saying there
were a thousand priests that helped it
wasn't just obviously not just him but
there were thousands of priests and then
would that also be similar to the daily
sacrificial but the Israelites did
because there were like a million people
that were encamped around the temple
Assassin a tabernacle sanctuary and I'm
just wondering how they how could they
perform all those sacrifices when there
were so many people yeah and you know
I'm not sure if it's saying that he
dedicated all these to be sacrificed or
and they were all done that day or he
dedicated them that day and they were
then sacrificed it is an amazing thing
when you look at the numbers and like I
said the only other historical comment
we've got on that is Josephus and he
says that the Jews sacrifice I thought
he said two hundred and fifty thousand
lambs I have to I might have to
double-check that but it was a lot
during the Passover and again they had
like I said they had a tunnel that a man
could easily crawl through to carry all
the blood that came from the sacrifice I
know it sounds pretty gory Wow
yes as all supposed to represent the
atonement for sin which is a kind of
horrific now that the you know the
sacrifices were not wasted you go to you
go to an American slaughterhouse today
and you'll see that same river of blood
and people who thrown it in a hamburger
but the Jews did eat the sacrifices and
the priests mm-hmm okay well thank you
very much I appreciate your answer all
right thanks you're gonna make me do
more study on my own next quality we
have is Carlos listening in Sacramento
California
Carlos welcome to the program hello I
love you all very much
well thank you thanks for calling yes
I'm actually from Blackwood New Jersey
Oh my question is recently I replied to
a sermon with a pastor dog on a Sunday
truly sacred and it appeared to ruffle
some folks feathers so my question is
how do I respond to people when I'm you
know I make a post I share the truth and
they don't want to hear it how do I
reply like Jesus or should I not even
reply well you know if if this stuff
goes on on blogs very rarely does a
person get convinced as that folks are
sort of blogging their opinions I think
it's not in the Bible but Mark Twain
said a person convinced against their
will is of the same opinion still and
I've not seen a lot of folks converted
through argumentation if people are
seeking and in a Christian tone you say
you know if you're still open here's
some thoughts you might want to read
this and I have met people matter of
fact I I've met someone this weekend who
came to an evangelistic series and he
just argued and derided the Evangelist
and was very mean and talked about how
wrong he was and then he told me make
sure and apologize to that evangelist
because I came around and he accepted
the truth yeah you know you can't always
convince a person you might post what
you believe Jesus had a lot of people
that didn't accept the truth and I think
about that rich young ruler Jesus had
fallen
you know you'll have treasure in heaven
and he turned away and Jesus didn't go
chase after him and shake him and say
you gotta follow me to follow me you
can't make a person he gives everyone a
free will as long as a person is open
and sincerely listening well you can
communicate what folks start to be
resistant and a little hostile you can
get the idea that they're not really
open and at that point you stop pushing
especially if you're a parent you know
and you're trying to reach your children
or you're trying to reach a relative or
you have an unconverted spouse you got
to be careful not to preach to them all
the time try and win them if they're
open if you see they're genuinely
interested but don't nag oh you know
whether you're doing it online or you
just make yourself obnoxious after a
while they don't want to hear you
anymore so you know someone asked me a
question I'll answer it now if they're
open I'll give them more information but
as soon as they start just becoming
argumentative I say hey well we may have
to respectfully disagree that's where I
leave it I thank you Carlos appreciate
that in six days God created the heavens
and the earth for thousands of years man
has worshiped God on the seventh day of
the week now each week millions of
people worship on the first day what
happened why did God create a day of
rest does it really matter what day we
worship who was behind this great shift
discover the truth behind God's law and
how it was changed visit Sabbath truth
com next quality we have is Henry in
Bronx New York
Henry walking with the program yes for
you my question is when Christ comes
back he said that the son doesn't even
know I mean Jesus Christ is God Almighty
how can he face it he said the Sun
doesn't know when he's coming back yeah
good question you know Jesus talking
about the second coming he says of that
day and they I by the way I think that's
Matthew 24 is it's in a couple places I
think it's in mark and Matthew pastor
Ross is gonna look up the reference he
said no man knows the day in the hour
not that not even the son but the father
only and so someone they're going what
do you mean Jesus did not know the day
in the hour of his coming
well when Christ was on earth
as a human he laid aside a lot of his
divinity and he did not have all
knowledge swirling around in his brain
because he became a man and the other
thing is it wasn't even important for
him to know that because he wasn't going
to tell anybody and suppose that Jesus
didn't know the date and he had said all
right just I want to tell everybody I'm
gonna be coming in November in 2030 I
don't any one quote me on that but if
just suppose Jesus said that well the
calendar wasn't even the same back then
and they didn't know what 2030 meant
because they hadn't started dating from
his birth and so the date would have
been irrelevant if he had said I know
the date does Jesus know now of course
he does he's on the right hand of the
Father and why would the father withhold
any information Jesus knows everything
he was just saying while he was on the
earth he said you know I'm not even
gonna tell you I know the day in the
hour only the father knows that but now
he knows he's you know he's reassumed
his glory the verse you're referring to
there is Mark chapter 13 verse 32 it
says of the day in the hour and knoweth
no man not even the angels in heaven nor
the son but the father only mmm-hmm yeah
so when people start telling us they
figured out the day in the hour for his
coming you want to be very careless
careful about that Henry hey thanks so
much we appreciate your question next
full of it we have is Chris listening
from Florida Chris welcome to the
program hi Chris you're on the air nope
I might have lost him we've got still
there it's a different Chris let's try
yeah hear me Chris in New Mexico yes
okay thank you guys
divorce and remarriage if you remarry
somebody that has been married before do
you lose your salvation well the Bible
tells us there are certain sins that are
unpardonable but it never says that's
the one that is unpardonable you know it
would be reckless for us to say that
every person who's remarried without
biblical grounds is going to lose their
salvation the Bible says that it's a sin
the Bible also tells us adultery is a
sin David had no right
to marry Bathsheba he took another man's
wife and David was punished for his sin
but David and Bathsheba are gonna be in
heaven the Bible makes it pretty clear
definitely can't be the unpardonable sin
then you got Abraham that he took a
second wife he had two wives at one at
once and Jacob had four and that's
obviously not God's plan but Jacob's
gonna be in heaven and from what we read
most of his wives is it a sin Jesus went
to the Samaritan woman and he he pointed
out what she was doing was sinful she
had been married five times and she was
then living with a man she wasn't
married to Jesus confronted her with her
sin no doubt she repented but then he
revealed he's the Messiah so it must not
be the unpardonable sin or why would he
why would he reveal himself and his
salvation to the woman at the well right
that's John chapter four mm-hmm and he
validated those marriages of five
different marriages well he didn't
validate them I wouldn't say that
I mean God forgives sins that so would
be one thing he wasn't saying that all
those marriages were suddenly validated
I think that what God did is he he
forgave her past sins I'm assuming she
repented and you know there's you can't
unscramble scrambled eggs sometimes you
come to the Lord and you you've got a
scrambled background and if God wants
everybody to fix all the mistakes to the
background most of us are hopeless
because we've all done things we regret
and how are you gonna change the outcome
of every decision you've made in the
past
the unpardonable sin we have a book well
we have two books but we can tell you
about or anybody that has questions on
the line of what you're asking Chris we
have a book on marriage that's called
marriage divorce and remarriage it goes
through all the primary scriptures on
that subject and and puts it together I
think in a very understandable way and
we'll send you a free copy of that if
you'd like yeah the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again just ask for the
book called marriage divorce and
remarriage again 808 three five six
seven four seven we'll be happy to send
that book to anyone who calls and asks
and then are you gonna mention there's
also a book on the unpardonable sin
because you're kind of asking
about what is the unpardonable sin and
other people out there may be wondering
that and we've got that book that simply
says what is the unpardonable sin the
number there again is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone line and you
can ask for the book the unpardonable
sin if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
again that's eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven well pastor
Doug I think we're coming up on our mid
program break probably don't have enough
time to take another call but we just
took it before the program about a new
resource that amazing facts has it's
actually a DVD that talks about Daniel
chapter two along with some other
amazing prophecies it's called kingdoms
in time absolutely this is something
that we're very excited about and a
matter of fact people can it's on Amazon
Prime now it's on pure flix these major
corporations saw the documentary and
they said wow if you'd like to know how
to get a copy just call or call amazing
facts or go to a website which is
amazing fact dot o-r-g kingdoms and time
goes through the most powerful
prophecies in the Bible and proves the
Bible's true we'll be right back for
your questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 thousand and
we're gonna get back to the phones I am
pastor Doug my name is pastor Ross and
we gonna go to our next colder we have
passed the Kris listening from looks
like West Virginia Pastor Chris welcome
to the program well thank you so much I
am calling for a friend we were studying
your study guide the ultimate
deliverance on the coming of Jesus and
the question arose about the comma being
in the wrong place where Jesus says
surely today you will be with me in
paradise
of course you know we know the comma is
in the wrong place we know Jesus didn't
take the feast that day because he says
later on that
don't touch me for I did not get us into
my father but the question is we believe
that God has preserved his word and why
didn't the question was asked why didn't
God preserve the punctuation why did God
allow the punctuation to be put in the
wrong spot well keep in mind what we're
talking about is not preserving the Word
of God and the original languages we're
talking about a translation anybody can
make a translation you're talking about
the English translation the translators
were people like you and me they're not
inspired they're not Peter James and
John
heaven forbid but I could do The
Bachelor version if I could do a
translation probably be full of mistakes
but the original I believe the Word of
God is protected and preserved and God
has its the infallible Word of God but
the King James translation that's why
there's so many English translations as
they've all seen that their strengths
and weaknesses whenever you go from one
language to another especially when you
consider there was no punctuation in the
original Greek so were there errors in
punctuation and yes sometimes they if
it's like that that verse we talked
about being baptized for the dead that's
confused a lot of people it's really a
punctuation error in the English
translation so the guys that work for
King James that did the translating did
an incredible job
and the King James Bible is a
masterpiece and I do believe that it's a
you know wonderful but it is not
flawless it's the Word of God that is
flawless we're gonna we're getting a lot
of background noise Chris pastor Chris I
hope we that hope that helps a little
bit with your question we're gonna bring
you back up again does that make sense
okay one more one more thing where can I
see a copy of the original Greek to know
that there's no punctuation in it well
as far as if you're looking for an
original copy of John's letter or Paul's
letter we there's no originals they have
Greek manuscripts that you can look at
you can even see them online and you'll
see that there was none of the
punctuation that we have now the Hebrew
did have some punctuation that's what
Jesus talked about that not one jot or
tittle that was some of their
punctuation --zz will pass from the law
till all is fulfilled but a Greek did
not have punctuation you just look
online and and you can probably see
some copies of some of the Greek
manuscripts of the word of God and even
the Strong's Concordance you can
actually look up the verse and we'll
show you the original Greek words it's
used and you can see there's no
punctuation you can buy out Bible it's
called a transliteration we're right
underneath each word you'll see the
Greek equivalent of that word I have it
on my computer here and the other
translators just had to add comments for
the English might affect it some of the
early English didn't have punctuation
you go back and you read some of the
very early English Bibles and
manuscripts you get like Shakespeare
yeah I mean he had to guess where their
punctuating next called it that we have
these Charles listening in Florida
Charles welcome to the program hey how's
it going pastor Doug good thanks for
calling I have a question that revolves
around to the last days how will we how
will we know where to go when we're
running in the last days for safety or a
good question you know Jesus talked
about the the abomination of desolation
you can read that in Matthew 24:15 he
said those that are in Judea flee into
the mountains and Luke says when you see
Jerusalem surrounded with armies flee
into the mountains in the last days
God's people once again are gonna be
hedged in by the beast power with laws
you can't buy or sell and the folks are
wonder you know if you have to flee
where do you go well you know I believe
that God is gonna guide us then the same
way he guided the children of Israel
when they left Egypt he guided him with
a pillar of fire when he Elisha fled
from Jezebel you know he somehow found
his way back to Mount Sinai God I think
guides us at those crucial times I'm not
worried about will I have a GPS or a
compass with me and where am I going to
go though I'll admit I found a couple
places out in the wilderness I made a
special note and I said if that day
comes this would be a good spot so I'm
not telling anybody where they are
anyhow but I do think God's Spirit will
guide us then and we don't have to worry
about you know lugging a trailer full of
food with us I think it's a nice day I
forget the verse it says your bread and
water will be sure in that time right so
I think if
God's gonna guard us it says he'll give
his angels charge over you to keep you
in all of your ways and the same way
angels fed Jesus in the wilderness and
they fed Elijah I think God is going to
sustain his people when we have to flee
during that time hey man that's what I
look forward to
yeah the verse you're referring to there
is Isaiah chapter 33 verse 16 where we
have the promise that God will provide
for his people
next what we have is let's see we've got
Debbie in Sacramento Debbie welcome to
the program hi hi thanks for calling I'm
gonna put you on privacy okay so I lost
my mom a couple years ago and I've been
grieving really really strongly and a
search God's Word I searched the
Scriptures because I would like a deeper
understanding it's exactly where my mom
went when she took her last breath in
one scripture I read absent from the
body as present with the Lord in another
scripture I read the dead know nothing
they are asleep in another scripture yet
I read the breath of God returns back to
him I love Jesus and I'd like to know
what happens when I die too
can my mom see me could she hear me
because in Scripture it also says that
all of heaven rejoices when one one lost
is saved how does all of heaven know do
they know what's going on here on earth
I would really like some peace of mind
please help me okay thank you we'll do
our best every appreciate your question
first of all all the scriptures are true
and there's no conflict when it says for
example in Ecclesiastes when any
creature dies you notice it doesn't say
good or evil there it says the spirit
returns to God who gave it and that
simply means the breath of life that
word there is wrong
it means the breath of God returns to
God who gave it when you die it's not
talking about a ghost or some conscious
being when Jesus went to Lazarus to
resurrect him he said our friend Lazarus
is asleep I go to wake him now when a
believer dies they are sleeping a a
dreamless sleep no consciousness of time
until the resurrection when is the
resurrection it tells us in first
Thessalonians the Lord will descend from
heaven with a shout and the dead in
Christ will rise when he comes
but to be absent from the body is to be
present with the Lord
that's because if you have no
consciousness of time your next
conscious thought when you die and
you're saved is the presence of the Lord
but people up in heaven when those in
heaven are rejoicing when someone saved
their the Lord is talking about the
angels it's as the angels sing the
angels rejoice believers that die it's
like Christ said of Lazarus they're
asleep there's about a dozen
resurrections in the Bible none of the
people who were raised ever commented on
going to heaven are going to hell or
experiencing anything in death that
they're sleeping a beautiful dreamless
sleep waiting for the resurrection
because keep in mind we know the
resurrections in the future John chapter
6 that says the resurrection the last
day and we know the judgments in the
future it's called the day of the Lord
and so God's not giving out rewards
before a resurrection and a judgment but
for the believer when they die you know
we live in time they have no
consciousness of time for them it's
instant see what I'm saying have you
ever had a hard night hard day's work
and you go to sleep and you look at the
clock and say I couldn't have possibly
slept six hours and felt like two
minutes yeah well that's what's gonna be
like for the believers it's gonna be
like a moment Paul says a twinkling of
an eye there in the resurrection now we
have I'd like you to understand this
better Debian we have a free offer we
would like to give you please send for
it anyone out there if you're wondering
about this subject many Christians are
confused yes it's a study guide part of
our mazing facts series of lessons is
called are the dead really dead and it's
actually I hope filled study when you
discover what the Bible really teaches
on this I'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks the number
again our resource phone line is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the study guide called are the
dead really dead or bad per to send it
to anyone who calls and asks
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch to
contact the spirit of a deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter we invite you to look inside and
find out for yourself visit death truth
calm our next call of the behalf is
let's see we got to Marcus in New Mexico
Marcos welcome to the program thank you
pastor Roz and pastor dad my question is
in a book of Joshua chapter 10 verse 12
to 13 shall I read it sure it's talking
about the battle of AI when the Sun
Stood Still right yes you know the
context the Lord was helping this ray
likely see the amorite that day so about
the noon Joshua prayed to the Lord loud
enough what is realized to hear Oh Lord
make the Sun is top in the sky over
Divya and the moon is standing still
over a lone Valley so the Sun and the
moon stopped and stood still until the
Israelite Israel deceived its enemies
yes so did God he stopped the Sun in the
moon for the whole universe or he
brought the substitute just for that
area just like when Jesus was born the
Angels form they starts between these
effect the weekly cycle you know a lot
of people have wondered what happened
astronomically when God did this not
only here in the story of Joshua but you
also have and I forget the passage where
Hezekiah is at Isaiah 39 maybe where God
made the Sun go backwards I mean it's
one thing to slow it down but put it in
reverse the Sun went backwards 10
degrees and everyone wonders how does
God do that one at that like make the
earth stop spinning and send everyone
flying off the planet from the
centrifugal interruption and and how did
you stop the stunts and you know what I
have no doubt believing that God can do
that and make it all work I mean he's
the one who brought the Sun and the moon
into existence I don't think it was an
optical illusion for the people I think
God basically made time stand still so
it doesn't affect the weekly cycle
how he did that astronomically I'll look
forward to getting to heaven and asking
him I don't know
yeah whatever day that was if there was
a Wednesday or a Thursday or a Sunday or
whatever was it was a very long day but
the Sun did set and then the next day
was the next day Monday Tuesday whatever
it might have been I felt like I've had
some of those things before where the
Sun this wouldn't go down you know we do
that passage I was thinking about
traveling I'm flying to Singapore later
on this month and I I leave on one day
you know I coming back I leave on a
Monday morning fly 15 hours and I land
one hour after I took off the same day
and if you take off at sundown like from
San Francisco and you're heading that
direction it is the longest sundown you
ever see cuz you're tracking with the
Sun and especially if you're up near the
pole Sun doesn't go down yeah it's
interesting
so how he did this great question Marco
so I'm not sure what the answer is I
believe the Word of God and I believe it
happened Mexico law that we have is Glen
listening in Sacramento
Gwen welcome to the program hi there and
thank you very much actually I'm in
Smithville I just never speak until
Montana just never changed my phone
number okay the question that I have is
with with discussions we're trying to
figure out when Adam and Eve sinned it
was Adam deceived or was his decisions
knowingly well I think Adam knew you
know God had told Adam and Eve do not
eat the forbidden fruit Adam did not
have any Alzheimer's back then he knew
it was still fresh in his mind that they
were not supposed to eat this fruit but
I think he looked and he saw well Eve
ate it and she's still alive and he
loved her so much he thought even though
he had probably terrible foreboding he
thought whatever her fate is I'm I'm
gonna share it with her you know no
doubt the same way the devil was
tempting Eve he was urging Adam we all
can be tempted in her minds I'm sure
Satan was whispering to Adam you know do
it you'll lose even I don't know what
the devil was telling him I don't think
Adam was deceived as much as a woman
matter of fact where is it the New
Testament Paul says the woman being
deceived so well what happened with Eve
was more of a
I think Adam went into it a little more
eyes wide open first Timothy chapter 2
verse 14 that says and Adam was not
deceived but the woman being deceived
fell into transgression so Eve was
deceived Adam knowingly chose to disobey
yeah he I guess he put his love for Eve
above his love for God who made Eve and
a lot of people still do the same thing
they put the love for a person above
their love for God
and I meant people before they said you
know I'm not gonna get baptized till my
wife does I'm not going to come to Jesus
until they do and they're really putting
someone else ahead of the Lord when they
do that hey thank you so much appreciate
your question and Gwen next caller that
we have is Bill listening in Illinois
bill welcome to the program
oh gosh Doug Pastor John how are you
good thank you how are you not too bad
my question is about the New Testament
the writings of Paul where he talks
about eating meat that's been sacrificed
to idols yes and it says that eating it
or not eating it is nothing and so if
I'm understanding that correctly I'm not
really sure does that mean that it's
okay to do that and the reason I'm
asking that is because in Revelation it
makes you kind of sound like God hates
it and gets angry if you do it and so
I'm just kind of wondering you know Paul
makes it sound like kind of like it's
okay but then in Revelation he makes it
sound like it's not okay well there were
two different I shouldn't say they're
two there there's a couple different
things happening here there was times
when they ate things offered to idols
because they were sacrificing to idols
and believers were sitting there
participating in a sacrifice to an idol
and eating the sacrifice the way priests
used to eat a sacrifice to Jehovah and
then there were people who went to the
marketplace to buy their food and there
in the marketplace where everybody
bought their food they had a little
statue of an idol where whenever the
chicken was set you know sacrifice there
was an idol there and Paula saying look
when you buy something in the
marketplace don't ask if it was offered
to an idol if you're eating with a
brother and he's worried about it being
offered to an idol in the marketplace
don't eat it if it's gonna make him
stumble but you know the idol isn't
and that's kind of like have you ever
been to a Chinese restaurant bill where
the proprietors had a little Buddha in
the restaurant yeah that's very common
did that worry you about eating in a
restaurant where people had a little
statue of Buddha or did you think well
I'm you know I'm not gonna worship
Buddha but I'm gonna enjoy my my you
know egg foo yung or whatever it is
you're eating if I went to a Chinese
restaurant with a friend who had a very
sensitive conscience they said Oh Doug
we can't eat here look they're burning
incense the Buddha will be worshipping
Buddha I'll say okay let's eat Mexican
and we leave Paul said don't do anything
to make your brother's stumbled if his
faith is weak just eat vegetables don't
eat any meat when you're with him but
when it says in Revelation eating those
things sacrifice to idols those are
people I think went into the temples to
participate in the sacrifices it was it
was not talking about buying you know
going to the the supermarket where they
might have had a little Idol in the
marketplace all over the Greco Roman
Empire there as someone said there were
more idols than they had tiles on the
roof the Jews that were very sensitive
when they'd go and they'd go to the meat
market and they'd buy even the clean
meat goat cheap chicken whatever it was
they had little idols there right by the
butcher block and they said well I can't
eat that and then Paul said look don't
get carried away that doesn't matter
you're not worshiping the idol you're
not offering it to the idol but that was
different than going into the temple of
the idols are these false gods I thank
you bill good question I hope that helps
a little bit and we're gonna try and get
a couple more in we've got chase
listening from Illinois chase welcome to
the program hi Pastor John and hi out
pastor Doug I have a question what does
the Bible say about practicing martial
arts and like just to kind of give more
context about it I used to I used to
practice I study coming through but like
my conscience has been like really
unsettled I'm about it because there are
some occult practices within that
martial art yeah you know that's a good
question and I need to answer this
carefully you know they're all around us
here in Sacramento there's just all
kinds of places where kids go and they
learn judo or Hapkido and
my son was in the Marines and it's
required they all learned you know
because judo is a very valid form of
wrestling self-defense and disarming
somebody they get Hapkido they got
karate they got the Taekwondo I mean
there's so many different forms of it
some of them are they if they start
getting into the religious aspects of it
I wouldn't get near that if they're
talking about something where you know
your kids are learning some discipline
and getting some physical exercise
hopefully they're not going through
their school karate chopping I know I
took a couple of karate classes and the
first thing you want to do is try it out
on everybody and so you don't want to
teach your kid violence if you're a
Christian but if they're doing something
just for physical exercise you know they
got a lot of energy to burn off and give
them some goals I'd be I'd be careful
about condemning it people will say all
that can some of its trace back to the
mysticism and then you need to be
careful so it probably would depend on
what's what particular science they're
taking and and you know if they're
bringing in the Eastern mysticism and so
don't have anything to do with that and
I think also the further person gets
involved in that system it's more than
just you know the the exercise part of
the self-defense part but as you get
higher up and start teaching and maybe
get a little more involved in the
background of this yeah there's probably
some of that that comes into it some of
the ideology least an ideology
meditation that kind of thing yeah as a
Christian I don't know if you want to
spend all your time in self-defense
training right right it's almost like
you're spending hours and hours
anticipating that maybe someone will
attack you and he could become a
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah well I
thank you very much for helping me out
because that that was kind of like the
mine that I had it was like okay yeah
it's probably not a good idea but I just
thank you for helping me to clarify all
right hey thank you so much appreciate
your question all right next caller that
we have is Jimmy listening in New Mexico
Jimmy welcome to the program hi how are
you guys tonight good thank you for
calling in your question I just wanted
first of all I want to just say thank
you to both of you for what you're doing
god bless you guys my question is
I'm I'm just have a little thing with
this reprobate mind things that sound in
the book of Romans what can you tell me
about it more well and I think you might
also find it in is it second Corinthians
13 it says examine ourselves lest we be
found reprobate and and the word
reprobate means rebellious that we've
got we harden our minds we harden our
hearts to what the Holy Spirit is saying
is I don't know pastor Ross may have it
looked up Romans chapter 1 verse 21 it
says even so they did like they did not
retain God in their knowledge God gave
them over to a reprobate mind so you
kind of a rebellious mind they didn't
they didn't want obey God they didn't
want to think about God yeah so it's
just hard in your hardening your heart
to the truth where God basically said
look if you're gonna reject the truth
I'm gonna give you up to your rebellion
and the worst thing the most frightening
words for me in that the book of Romans
is that God might give us up and the
Holy Spirit would stop striving with us
because we've made up our minds and
we've hardened our hearts and I think
heaven forbid and does that pretty much
mean that we're lost well if you if you
do it to a point where the Holy Spirit
doesn't speak to you anymore and you
grieve with the Holy Spirit yeah a
person can reach that point but I don't
I don't like to ever have anyone on the
phone things don't know have I committed
the unpardonable sin because most people
calling a Christian answer program have
not committed the unpardonable sin the
Holy Spirit's working on them but yes
there are people that have grieved away
the Holy Spirit because it does harden
their hearts and and they have no
interest in spiritual things okay they
don't want God telling them what to do
okay good so I do not have a reprobate
mind oh praise the Lord as long as your
conscience is sensitive and you're still
convicted of your sins you're still
willing to have God talk to you and
convict you and say lord help me yeah
then you're a reprobate mind means you
just kind of quote plug your ears and
you just won't listen to God okay that
sounds good thank you thank you very
much thank you that's a great question
and pastor else is probably a good
question to end on is just to remind
people that you know the holy s--t
it speaks to us through our lives in
life is so precious that we would listen
to the voice of the Holy Spirit Jesus
wants to give eternal life to everybody
but we need to be willing to hear him
and he says that if if we listen to him
he's calling us he stands at the door
and he knocks but we must open the door
he will not force his way into our lives
perhaps you never made that decision
friends to invite Jesus into your heart
you can do it right now you might be
sitting around the kitchen table or
driving up the road but wherever you are
you can just lift your heart to God and
say Lord I don't want to harden my heart
will you come into my heart will you
forgive my sins give me that gift of
eternal life and this can be a beginning
of a new life for you and a new birth if
friends we are we still have some
important announcements coming but we're
not going to be able to take any more
questions give us another chance call
next week God willing we'll be here and
we want you to remember check out the
website there is a plethora Kaleidoscope
Blizzard of truth just go to amazing
facts of dot o-r-g and click donate keep
us on the air
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com journey back
through time to the center of the
universe discover how a perfect angel
transformed into satan the arts villain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at
www.lazyguycooking.com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]